are you still playing titanfall 2 well
you'll be glad to hear there's a DLC
pack dropping next week and it's
completely free the add-on is called
colony reborn and I'm gonna run you
through everything it adds I'm Matt and
this gamespot news update is prepared
for titanfall first off colony reborn
adds a couple things from the original
titanfall it reintroduces the classic
map colony and the r101 assault rifle
equipped with an acog scope a new
execution called curb check is coming
too and it looks freaking brutal now for
the fun part on top of all that colony
reborn adds new paid cosmetic content
including two new prime Titans some new
camos and more it launches for all
platforms are March 30th but don't
forget to Like and subscribe so you're
the first person to know about the next
big DLC pack but hey I'm not quite done
yet titanfall to developer respawn is
holding a free weekend for the first
person shooter and it runs for March
30th to april third it includes access
to the full suite of multiplayer modes
as well as the gauntlet training mission
and the first level from the campaign
and guess what you'll be able to get
double xp for the whole weekend and
those two single player missions are
going to stay free forever it might just
be the best time to jump back into
titanfall 2 but if you can't wait to do
battle with a giant robot check out our
video where we take down the massive
architect boss in Mass Effect Andromeda
[Music]
you